what's going on everyone i've got a fun
topic today how to make a million
dollars and so i know this is uh almost
clickbaity
uh but i want to uh go over it mostly
because
it's like one of the number one
questions i get all the time and so we
might as well actually break down the
math for you and so the number one way
that i know that someone has no
chance in actually doing this is they
don't even know the math behind how to
accomplish their goals
right and so that's what we're going to
break down today all right so the first
thing is
you have to know how many units or
whatever it is you're selling to get to
your goal right
and the question is do you want to make
a million dollars in revenue or do you
want to make a million dollars in take
home income
mind you to be in the top one percent in
america it's four hundred thousand
dollars a year
all right and so let's say you have a
business that runs 40 net margins which
mind you is very good
um if you run 40 at margins that means
if you made a million dollars in revenue
you would make 400 000 a year in net
profit what you get to take owner pay
right
from your business which is why by the
way i think that having a job
that pays well is very underrated i
think
it's just from being realistic if you
look at the odds i think it's
far far far more likely that you can
achieve
a six-figure or multi-six-figure income
fast by having a really high-paying job
because you've acquired a skill
then trying to learn basically all the
skills and own your own business
i'm just being candid and i think that
if i knew the amount of risk that i was
taking on when i started business i
don't know if i would have done it again
and i think that i had an atypical
entrepreneurial journey because i wasn't
really an entrepreneur personality type
i just
really hated my job enough that i was
going to do anything
but that and so that's what started it
but let's get to that let's get to the
mean the potatoes all right
so a lot of times people haven't even
figured out their price points on things
yet
and so the easiest way to understand
this is that if you have
a million dollars a year which is what
you want to make then you want to break
this down right so a million dollars a
year is going to be
83k per month all right roughly right
it's 83 333 whatever you could say 84k
but
83k per month all right that's what you
have to make in
uh revenue right now if you break it
down per day i think it's three three
three three three i think
um per day but if you if you do it per
week so let's just break this into
weekly
uh it would be like let's just say 21k
okay so 21k
per week all right and you'll notice i'm
gonna keep breaking this down because
it's really difficult to hit fuzzy
targets right i heard this from jason
flatland
fuzzy targets don't get hit right so we
need to make this a very precise clean
pristine target all right so we got a
million dollars a year breaks down to
83k per month
21k uh per week excuse me 21k per week
and then from there you know seven seven
days would be about 3k plus per day
right
so so that's that's how we know how we
can get to that number
now i like weeks because weeks are like
normal cycles daily can be a little bit
too volatile until you get to like
10 feet you know uh 10 million plus per
year um
and so if we're if we're talking
starting out right 21k per week all
right
so the thing is is we just have to know
what the lifetime value of our customer
is and so let's say you're selling a
single product that has no upsells right
which is pretty common
um a single product that has no upsells
let's say your ltv is a thousand dollars
okay now i want to be really clear about
this
you don't have to sell a thousand dollar
widget for this for the math that i'm
about to share
with you to make sense all right it just
means that your total lifetime value of
a customer is a thousand dollars like
starbucks i think their ltv's like eight
thousand dollars and you're like holy
cow
well think about how many times you
purchased the starbucks over the last
you know 10 years
right it adds up and so for me i'll give
you a couple different examples of what
a thousand
ltv might be if i sold a course for a
thousand dollars and i sold nothing else
that would be 1000
ltv if i sold a 100 a month gym
membership and the person on average
stays ten months
that would be a thousand dollar ltv if i
sold uh let's say
ah crap if i sold uh uh skin care
products right and the average order
value was
you know 250 and the average amount of
time that someone stayed on my
cream products was four months one
thousand dollars was my ltv okay
so these are all different ways of
achieving a thousand dollar ltv which
makes this hopefully
a little bit simpler now if i have to
get to a million dollars then i need to
sell 21 units
per week right and so that would be 21
divided by a thousand which is 21 right
units per week to hit our goal and so if
i know that i only really sell five days
a week monday through friday
right then it means i got to sell four
or maybe five i'd probably make five my
goal so i overshoot it a little bit
so i gotta sell five deals a day right
and if i have five deals a day and the
nice thing is with this process that i'm
walking you through right now
like you can add as many zeros as you
want it works the same way right you can
add zeros to your product zeros to your
goal
like everything works the same way so
it's five deals a day is what i have to
close
now the thing is is i may know my math
right and know that five deals a day
we close let's say one out of three one
out of three phone calls which means i'm
going to do 15 phone calls a day who
show up
right and now if i'm selling products
and it might be
based on site conversion so if i have
like you know one percent conversion on
my store
an e-commerce store for example then i
would need a hundred times the amount of
sales i need right so if i need five
quote sales per day with an
uh the lifetime value of a thousand and
i know that it takes
a hundred clicks to get one purchase
then i need 500 clicks a day hopefully
that makes sense here
but i'm just walking through a more a
more service-based sale because
it was top of mind all right so 15 calls
right per day
and let's say that i know my show up
rate on these calls is you know 66
so i'd have 22 set appointments per day
right
and the thing is is i know that based on
my either outreach efforts
it takes let's say i don't know 50
outreach efforts to get one appointment
i need a thousand outreach efforts a day
right now mind you a thousand dollar
deal would not be worth any kind of
effort like that so
because this is way way too low to have
kind of like a hand-to-hand combat
uh sale type type system um this would
probably need to be closer to like ten
thousand dollars
um and then there you go you get your 10
million
but but i'm using this just to
illustrate uh like the different ways to
get there right
and so um a nice thing to think about
this is that if you if you take
out if you take this little number here
your deal size right
and you put that as the main variable
for this process right you could either
sell you know
nine 10k deals
per month and have a million dollar
business
wow right you could sell one
100k deal per month to have a million
dollar business
that sounds pretty chill you could also
sell 100
well roughly you know 83 right
1k deals per month that sounds a little
harder right
or if you have hundred dollar widgets
you got to sell
god 830 right or 33 whatever it is
times 100 per per month to hit that
83k right and so you can kind of see how
much harder it gets
the lower the price like it's it's hard
to sell 833 things every month
i mean that's that's a lot of work right
and honestly it's hard to sell 83 things
a month
selling nine easier right and so it's
been
this is just the conclusion that i've
made throughout my life is
that especially when you're starting out
i think it's easier to start with
premium things as in like it's easier to
just
over deliver like crazy for a client
rather than trying to think about like
how do i make this scalable it's like
you don't need to worry about that yet
like you need to just start making money
right and so it's like how can i just
how can i how can i find a sweet spot in
here right this like five thousand ten
thousand fifteen thousand dollar mark
how can i find a sweet spot in here
where i can just provide tremendous
value to someone
um that they will want to continue to do
services with me and
i don't have to have a tremendous amount
of operational skill because the reason
that this is so hard for people this
hundred dollar month or even ten dollar
month range
is it's the operations behind it you
have to be able to support so much
volume
uh that you're very good with people and
that's a totally different skill than
learning how to market and sell and
acquire customers
and so this is where i think most people
kind of run into trouble and why a lot
of people who end up making more money
earlier
kind of focus on this on this upper side
of the ladder
there's a very very very few exceptions
of people who uh make a lot of money
like super
super rare make a lot of money below
this thousand dollar
um you know per unit price tag right
like you have to find a way
to get your ltv higher because it's just
too hard like acquiring customers is
just too difficult
to not have a high ltv and like like i
said starbucks right 8000 ltv so it
doesn't have to be your ticket price
that has to be low
it's just like you have to find ways to
make customers worth more
right unique expensive sticky air if you
remember that from before habit forming
something that they want to continue to
come back again and again and again
so anyway how to make a million dollars
i think most people do not do this math
on this
which is you got to make twenty one
thousand dollars a week and then there's
a zillion ways to make twenty one
thousand dollars a week right you can
sell hundred dollar units you can sell a
thousand units you can sell ten thousand
units because a hundred thousand dollar
units
um but at the end of the day that is how
you do it and if you're thinking about
this from a sales professional
standpoint so i'll break this down for
you guys as a bonus because i know a lot
of sales people follow our stuff
um make this whatever your product is
your commission
right so if you want to make a million
dollars as a salesperson
right then you need to sell like unless
you get a thousand commission then you
need to
sell 83 units a month of your thing
right and that may sound crazy and that
it is because that's why you know that's
why the top one percent is
you know half of that in terms of income
right and so uh but if you can if you
can figure out that a thousand dollars
you know if you can get your like you
should be able to think in your mind
like
this is my income goal as a salesperson
this is what i would like to make is the
amount of calls
you know or calls taken required to hit
this goal uh reasonable
right because on some level every every
position has a cap
based on time right how much how much
time you could allocate right there's
only 24 hours in a day
and so anywho reverse the math on your
own business and your own
products that you're selling and a lot
of times this will help you get your
goals a lot faster so anyway keeping
awesome lots of love and i'll catch you
guys soon bye